[Musik]
bom dia
meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einer weiteren
episode minecraft mit luca staffel 2 ich
habe die letzte episode ja hier in
diesem trubel
beim herbstlichen wald bio dingsbums was
auch immer beendet und haben wir
wirklich eine menge leute den kroaten
luka bleibt da das zu unfassbar schön
hier und ja ich weiß sie auch extrem
allerdings sind ja wirklich bisher nun
diese richtung gelaufen doch nicht in
die andere richtung und haben unsere
welt in richtung studium
ich
versuche mal einen so ein bisschen zu
streicheln
[Musik]
was war das
hier wurden generell zahlreiche tipps in
die kommentare geschrieben man meister
das übrigens
wo wir erst mal aufgeschrieben luca
diese diese diese braunen schafe haben
eine chance von 0 15 prozent
es gibt vorliegenden anderen youtuber
der sich als aufgabe gemacht hat dieses
braune schlaf zu finden und hat dafür
mehrere tage
in minecraft verbracht also jetzt nicht
minecraft tage soll ein wirklich
zahlreiche stunden in seinem projekt und
hat dieses braune schafft ein immer erst
irgendwie ganz am ende gefunden oder so
ich habe keine ahnung dass wurden aber
zahlreich und in die kommentare
geschrieben da dachte ich mir einfach
nur so einfach rum habe ich so ein glück
dass das schaf direkt ankommt was ist
das hier
das sind auch kürbisse
okay ich bedanke mich darauf
das stinktier der faultiere mal nicht
dankeschön auf jeden fall für eure
zahlreichen kommentare was diese tipps
angeht ich brauchte wirklich hilfe bei
diesen ganzen neuen tieren monstern et
cetera und ich weiß zwar nicht was mit
diesen braunen scharf anfangen sollen
außer dass es mir hat braune wolle gibt
aber ich kann doch einfach ein weißes
schaf haben also ich glaube so
geisteskrank heftig ist es jetzt nicht
dass ich mich deswegen länger noch darum
kümmern muss die sache ist allerdings
dass mir da hinten slava
[Musik]
ich will eigentlich
nichts machen und hier geht es nirgendwo
hin
ok verlassen wir den raum direkt wieder
und konzentrieren uns darauf dass wir
zurück gelangen zu unserem sport
beziehungsweise zu unserer kleinen
keller base denn das ist das ziel für
heute meine lieben freunde nicht nur
dass ich da hin zurück gelangen sondern
dass ich generell die andere seite heute
mal so ein bisschen erkunde da habe ich
euch ja in der letzten episode gefragt
ob ich dann also ein bisschen wieder
dahin zurück laufen soll den schnee
billionen haben wir eigentlich alle
geschrieben lokal ab jetzt kommen wieder
zurück jetzt entdeckt man mal die andere
seite wie hummeln kindes
[Musik]
wie ihn das noch mal
ich hab einfach mit der
[Musik]
ist aber auch egal mit liebe freunde ich
weiß nicht ob ich das jetzt eingesammelt
habe diese komische bienenwabe
allerdings habe ich die nicht
eingesammelt
ist jetzt kaputt gegangen
ich dachte man muss nun lagerfeuer
darunter setzen damit die bienen nicht
sauber ist aber auch egal mein freund
ich brauche erstmal keine bienen es ich
gebe mich ersetzen um die wichtigen
dinge ist auch sehr schön hier
ist das flucht
[Musik]
ach das ist das ding wo wir schon waren
meine freunde ich habe mich die ganze
zeit wieder ablenken von dieser
wunderschönen welt die wir uns hier
kreiert haben in minecraft mit luca
staffel 2 wirklich
da ist wird dieser komische
note luca
phoenix honig sauger vogel wo wir auch
die zahlreichen die kommentare
geschrieben dass der doch tatsächlich
recht selten ist also auch wenn
[Musik]
das ding
das ich
brauche hier vorne die süß werden ab ich
brauche auch noch mehr hier die
fußballer ab und hier hier vorne haben
wir noch eine schlucht also es ist
wirklich sehr sehr krass was hier vorne
alles abgeht was wir hier generell für
möglichkeiten haben und was sie alles
abgeht mit den ganzen tieren und so
dahin waren rar oder eine fliege glaube
ich ich konzentriere mich allerdings
jetzt erst mal wirklich nur auf die
volle die nehme ich jetzt nämlich ab
jetzt immer mit weil ich ja auch die
schere jetzt ob die ganze zeit ab jetzt
die ganze zeit immer mit dabei habe borg
es ist noch nichts passiert in diesem
video aber es ist doch trotzdem schon
soviel passiert also wirklich
geisteskrank dankeschön auf jeden fall
für eure zahlreichen tipps was die
ganzen tiere angeht einerseits mit dem
schaf dann auch mit der möwe da wurde
mir geschrieben locker diese möwe du
hast nur diesen erfolg bekommen meinen
man meinen dass da weil die mögliche
etwas geklaut hat jetzt kann ich das
nicht mehr mitnehmen
machen was so
[Musik]
ein hund
und wie schön ist es hier bitte
mit diesen ganzen blumen und so
[Musik]
hat mir wurde auf jeden fall eine zug
auf die möwe geschrieben dass die mir
wohl was geklaut hat und ich weiß nicht
was also wenn ihr irgendwie daran
erinnern können was ich vorher
vielleicht items hat und danach
irgendwie nicht mehr dann schreib mir
auch gerne in die kommentare wir
konzentrieren ist allerdings erst mal
darauf hier einen großen bogen um den
sumpf zu machen denn ich habe keinen
bock hier wieder auf so ein krokodil zu
treffen deswegen laufen mit diesmal
wirklich so ein bisschen außen rum weil
mein leben gerade ist nicht so ganz
dafür gemacht dass jetzt ein krokodil
ankommen und wir ein bisschen den strich
durch die rechnung macht gerade ein
bisschen immer naja euch auf jeden fall
eine ganz kurze time lässt wie ich
zurück zu meiner keller base laufe
und da sind wir auch schon wieder in
unser vertrauten gegend hier angekommen
meiner lieben freunde hier ist ja unsere
kleine underground base die wir uns von
einigen folgen gebaut haben und ich
freue mich wirklich hier zu sein ich
werde allerdings gar nicht lange her
sein denn ihr wisst es ja bereits wir
haben auch noch immer nicht ein echter
sonst fault stinkt stinkerkäs faultier
ich wäre auf jeden fall nicht lange hier
sein denn meine lieben freunde ich werd
nur fix ein paar sachen sichern und mir
ein bisschen platz im inventar machen
wie beispielsweise das ganze holz war
hier reinpacken die ganzen welt in
sachen hier rein wie beispielsweise die
gold blöcke und dann werde ich hier
jetzt auch mal ganz kurz geben noch die
höfen entleeren und die wichtigsten
sachen hier vorne reinpacken die sache
ist allerdings dass ich da noch gar
nicht lange hier bleiben werde wenn wir
mal ganz kurz den verfügbaren reinhauen
und dann sehe ich auch gerade und immer
eine inventarliste dass ich immer noch
das kupfer dabei habe das pack ich auch
noch mal kurz rein denn wir gehen
tatsächlich direkt wieder auf reisen
meine lieben freunde die wichtigsten
sachen habe ich mit dabei bettchen was
zum sicheren werk bayern genügend essen
habe ich auf jeden fall auch mit am
start denn ich habe heute vor ein
bisschen in die richtung zu laufen jetzt
habe ich wieder meine süße beeren rennen
ich möchte mich heute ein bisschen in
die richtung hier bewegen und da so ein
bisschen schauen was hier so abgeht weil
klar wir wissen auch nicht ist dass sie
vorne in den see oder ist dass das meer
ist dass offen dahinten wir wissen
natürlich auch nicht was ist mit dem
meer da hinten da war ich ja in einer
teilnetz von ein paar folgen wo ich holz
abgebaut habe habe ich entdeckt dass
gott hinten er sich auch noch mehr
befindet hinter diesen bergen allerdings
noch nicht hier und ich will auch mal
schauen ob es vielleicht im schnee wie
um auch das ein oder andere neue tier
gibt hier vorn habe ich gerade eine
google sind eh wieder ein stinkendes
faultier gäste echte unfassbar danke
übrigens auch noch mal habe ich ja
gerade bereits schon gesagt allerdings
habe ich den einen kommentar vergessen
noch mal für eure ganzen tipps zu den
tieren mir wurde auch geschrieben luca
sonne ziege da musst du aufpassen wenn
ein bisschen länger vor der stets wird
die aggressiv es kann sein dass sie dann
auf dich los geht also da auch hier auf
jeden fall auch danke für eure tipps da
bin ich sehr dankbar über generell wenn
ihr weiter vorschläge habt oder
irgendwelche tipps hinweise und in die
kommentare die bären hier nämlich jetzt
auch mal mit was mir auch geschrieben
wurde war da meinte nämlich jemand luca
legoland sind meine lieblings mods in
minecraft und die kann man irgendwie
wohl ganz leicht selber machen indem man
zwei schnee blöcke übereinander nimmt
und dann setzt man die irgendwie hin und
dann setzt man darauf ein geschnitzten
kürbis
selbst als schneemann bin ich noch
deutlich heißer als luca okay der macht
auf jeden fall sein ding ich hoffe du
freut sich dass ich hier einen
lieblingsfilm ob kreiert habe dein
lieblingstier hier fahren mit den
kürbissen mit dem bisschen schnee drauf
es ist wirklich wundervoll ich feiere
ist hier wirklich so krass die haben
noch einen hund wir haben allerdings
leider noch keine knochen mit denen wir
diese hunde irgendwie zähmen können und
ich hätte auch eigentlich ehrlich gesagt
bock auf eine katze in diesem projekt
gegen den krieg war ich auch keinen bock
hab dass katzen ihr hier das prüfen wir
ihnen was in die luft sprengen die sache
ist allerdings dass ich auch echt
gespannt inwieweit sich diese schnee
hier zieht wir sind jetzt wirklich schon
ein bisschen hier drin und ich habe auch
ehrlich gesagt keinen bock dass wir hier
nur eine schneelandschaft schälen ich
weiß dass das mit der weihnachtszeit
ganz gut passt und dann könnte ich
vielleicht ein weihnachtsmarkt bauen und
blau und generell bin ich da sehr
dankbar für eure ganzen vorschläge was
ich alles bauen könnt aber das kriege
ich halt nicht alles im deswegen mal
schauen was hier nach noch so für biome
kommen ich bin auf jeden fall
also von hier vorne sind wir auf jeden
fall gekommen und wir laufen jetzt
einfach mal drüber in die richtung da
hinten da vorne sind ein paar schafe da
können wir da
[Musik]
kann man es ja direkt mal testen mit dem
kommentar also wenn ich zu lang von
einer ziege stehe dann wird sie
aggressiv
[Musik]
macht doch gar nichts
oder muss ich noch mehr irgendwie voll
[Musik]
ich habe hier gerade kohle abgebaut weil
in diesem neuen billionen yen wie eine
menge kohle ist allerdings sehe ich
gerade da unten irgendwelche komischen
lichter eingeblendet und ich weiß nicht
ob ich das jetzt irgendwie gerade falsch
interpretiere aber es scheint so
auszusehen als werden hier ins bonner
wert
was
mein gott was habe ich ja vorhin
vergessen können die wand hochklettern
bochumer idiot ich bin ein idiot das ist
spinnens motto mein gott ok krass ich
dachte eigentlich ich brauche auch alter
etwas geht jetzt abnehmen
geht es dann plötzlich so bei mir hier
ich dachte vol 1 auf entspannt ich
locker zu dem dorf auf einmal sehe ich
in so einer textur hier vor hier weiß
man spinnen eine stunde später okay ich
habe hier drin jetzt erstmal alles
ausgeleuchtet hier vorne geht es auf
jeden fall noch weiter in eine höhle
rein hier ist auch lava und so ich weiß
nicht auf welche höre ich bin habe ich
war relativ weit oben eigentlich den wir
fordern noch mal eben kurz das eisen mit
und jetzt haben wir hier auf jeden fall
ins bonner ich leuchte den mal komplett
aus hier von jeder seite ich habe auf
jeden fall eine menge spinnen gerade
getötet oben ist auch schon nach das
heißt ich werde jetzt auch mal ganz fix
sein bettchen nehmen um mich hier erst
mal ganz kurz hinlegen so dass auf jeden
fall von oben keine monster mehr kommen
können hey leute mein einziges ziel war
heute bisschen auf die kommentare
einzugehen mich bei euch bedanken für
die ganzen teams mit diesem neuen
modifikationen roma ein gott okay wir
haben schallplatten wir haben ich bin
einfach mal alles mit was hier drin war
zac wer mehr genügend platz im inventar
die sache ist allerdings dass ich ja gar
nichts mit diesem sbornaja anfangen kann
weil er mitten im niemandsland das aber
ich habe das satt gesehen auf diese
animation ging wie von der minimap oder
das hat auch zu vieler mit ihnen welchen
fackeln und sohn mit leichtigkeit mit
leuchtmitteln keine ahnung was deswegen
dachte ich mir schon mal hin weil hier
vorne ehe überall kohle war und nicht
die ganze kohle abgebaut habe weil ich
eigentlich
und läutet remax hier
[Musik]
du bist ja was
es hat noch nie was im wasser ein erstes
spiegelung von kripo glaube ich
war auf jeden fall auch action mit
diesem ganzen ganzen sachen hier dass es
wie wir da oben wieder
wer ist das
[Musik]
es gibt halt eins zu eins aus als wäre
dass irgendein anderer spieler hier
gerade in meiner minecraft welt online
wächst ihr meine lieben freunde ich
würde an der stelle die heutigen episode
minecraft mit luca jetzt auch beenden
wenn es euch gefallen hat dann nachts
gern einen daumen hoch unter dem video
hier da abonniert einen kanal und klickt
auf die glocke wenn ihr neue videos und
neue parks dieser serie minecraft mit
luca staffel 2 nicht verpassen wollte
ich weiß nicht was ich mit dieser person
die mit dem pfeil und bogen machen soll
was soll ich mit dem sport machen ich
war auch noch nicht in dem dorf hinten
das wird alles in der nächsten folge
morgen um 18 uhr patient also schaltet
da unbedingt wieder ein
ich bin angebot auf eure tipps schreibt
mir die kommentare was hier heute alles
passiert ist was das für teile waren
dass das filmmonster waren
es morgen uci
[Musik]